i want to thank uh president abbas for
this opportunity to speak to him once
again
uh the last time
that we had an extensive discussion was
in ramallah
uh during my visit to both israel
and the west bank and
at that time
i
said
to both sides that i remain deeply
committed and the united states remains
deeply committed
to bringing about a just and lasting
peace
to a conflict that has been going on too
low
and i want to say
that president abbas
i think has
consistently
rejected violence has recognized
the need for peace
and i'm grateful to him
uh for
uh his efforts
the position of the united states
uh has been clear
the border of israel and palestine
should be based on 1967's
lines
with mutually agreed to swaps so that
secure
and recognized borders are established
for both states with robust security
provisions so that israel
retains the ability to defend itself by
itself against any threats
and
you know i am very pleased that
president abbas
has
been willing to enter into
a negotiation
sitting directly at the table
we've seen palestinian and
israeli representatives
discuss some of the most difficult
issues that have been
roadblocks to peace for too long
none of us are under any illusion that
this will be easy as i said in my speech
this morning
it has already entailed significant
political risk
by president abbas as well as prime
minister netanyahu
but i think the reason that they've been
willing to take these risks is they
realize
this is
the best way the only way
for us to achieve
what should be our goal two states
living side by side in peace and
security
it's right for
palestinian children it's right for
israeli children
and
having leaders
who are willing to look out into the
future
and take risks on behalf of that better
history
is something that
the united states intends to support as
strongly as possible and i'm urging all
my counterparts uh heads of state here
at the united nations to support this
effort as well uh last point i would
make the palestinian authority
has been
a critical mechanism to
improve governance and increased
transparency
in the west bank
obviously
the palestinian authority
operates under significant constraints
including resource constraints
but we think it's very important that we
continue to support efforts that have
been made by the authority for example
to improve
uh internal security uh and
professionalize security forces uh
inside
uh the uh the authority uh and that i
think lays also an important foundation
for the kind of economic development
uh and governance that will be critical
for an independent palestinian state so
uh mr president thank you for taking the
time to be with me here today and i look
forward to our discussions
and
thank you very much uh mr president for
hosting us here and agreeing to meet
with us to discuss very critical
john kerry
and we still and our people still
remember very proudly the historical
visit that you paid to the palestinian
territories after which we launched
peace negotiations with your support and
help and also with the involvement of mr
carey
and
said
and we appreciate all the support that
the us is extending to the palestinian
people to build the state institut the
institutions of the future palestinian
state which hopefully will materialize
very soon with your support and
continued assistance
and as we have said in the past and we
continue to reiterate that we are fully
committed to the peace process so that
we can reach a final settlement that
will that ultimately will lead to the
creation of an independent palestinian
state that would live side by side in
peace and security with israel
today
and as you have indicated mr president
we have no illusions that peace would be
easy or
simple and we have to overcome several
difficulties but we realize that peace
in the middle east is not just important
for the palestinians and the israelis
it's important for the entire region and
the world
we appreciate your support for the
continuation of the negotiations and we
will
exert every effort possible to make sure
that they will succeed and to take
advantage of this historical opportunity
we understand there will be difficulties
that will do
thank you everybody